AND THAT'S IT FOR US TONIGHT.
GUTFELD NEXT.
♪♪
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: YES, HAPPY THURSDAY,
EVERYONE.
OH, WHAT A, WHAT A GREAT SHOW WE
HAVE.
BRET BAIER IS HERE.
YES!
I THINK IT'S BRET BAIER.
EITHER THAT OR IT'S TEDDY
RUXTON.
JUST IN CASE I PUT IF NEW
BATTERIES.
>> Bret: OKAY.
>> Greg: DAGEN McDOWELL IS HERE.
I KNOW BECAUSE I CAN SMELL THE
CRAW FISH IN HER PURSE.
SO AS THE COUNTRY REELS FROM A
BIZARRE HISTORIC RAID OF A
FORMER PRESIDENT'S HOUSE OUR
CURRENT PRESIDENT LEAVES FOR
VACATION.
LET'S HOPE HE TRIES PARA SAILING
OR FACE JUMPING OR EVEN MORE
DANGEROUS, TAKES THE STAIRS AT
THE HOTEL.
BUT HE CURVES A BREAK FOR AS YOU
KNOW HE'S DONE SO MUCH.
FIRST HE PUT ON HIS JACKET.
THIS AFTER HE SLOW DANCED WITH
IT FOR 15 MINUTES FIRST.
THAT WAS A CROWNING ACHIEVEMENT
OF HIS PRESIDENCY SO FAR JUST
ECLIPSING THAT TIME HE MADE A
SOLID BOOM BOOM IN THE PRESS
OFFICE BATHROOM.
WELL, NEAR THE PRESS OFFICE
BATHROOM.
SORRY BRET.
AFTER APPROXIMATELY FOUR MINUTES
OF ACTUAL WORK WHERE HIS HANDS
WERE BUSIER THAN A CNN PRODUCER
ON BRING YOUR DAUGHTER TO
WORKDAY, BIDEN HOPS ON A PLANE.
HE HOPS ON A PLANE, AND NOT JUST
WITH DR. JILL, YOU KNOW, THE
NOTED THE TV ACTRESS
NEUROSURGEON WHO DISCOVERED A
CURE FOR HEMORRHOIDS WHEN JOE
ACCIDENTALLY SAT ON A STACK OF
BINGO CHIPS, HE INVITED HIS SON
HUNTER TO FLY ALONG.
NOT SURE HUNTER REALLY NEEDS A
PLANE TO DO THAT.
SO THERE HE IS WITH JOE GETTING
READY TO LEAVE.
I THINK WE HAVE TAPE OF THE
ACTUAL FLIGHT WITH HUNTER.
YEP.
FRANKLY, WE'VE SEEN BETTER
BEHAVIOR ON THE LOLITA EXPRESS.
BY THE WAY, HE'S NOT THE ONLY
FREE LOADING FAMILY MEMBER WHO
ENJOYS FREE TRIPS ON YOUR DIME.
PELOSI'S SON ALSO ACCOMPANIED
HER ON THE RECENT TRIP TO
TAIWAN, YOU KNOW, THE TRIP THAT
ALMOST CAUSEDED A WAR.
SHE WANTS US ALL TO BELIEVE EVEN
THOUGH SHE AND HER HUSBAND HAVE
BUSINESS DEALINGS THERE, THAT'S
JUST A COINCIDENCE.
THAT'S LIKE HUNTER AND JOE
SAYING THEY JUST GO TO CHINA FOR
AUTHENTIC COME POW CHICKEN.
NANCY SAYS HER SON WAS THERE AS
HER ESCORT, TO WHICH HUNTER
SAID, DAM, THAT'S EVEN TOO KINKY
FOR ME.
BUT I GUESS SHE'S TRYING TO SAVE
FACE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: WHAT'S THE POINT?
NO SURPRISE, THOUGH, SHE'S DOWN
TO THE LAST THREE THAT SHE KEEPS
IN THE FRIDGE.
EVERY TIME SHE REACHES FOR A
PINT OF CHOCOLATE HAWINGEN DAWES
SHE'S LOOKING BACK AT HERSELF.
WHAT A CONTRAST OF HOW BIDEN
WERE TREATED, THEY'RE FLYING
AROUND WHILE TRUMP'S HOUSE GETS
RAIDED.
DID I SAY RAIDED? HOW DARE YOU
SAYS THE LOCK STEP LEMMINGS
WORKING FROM THE SAME SCRIPT.
>> I KNOW DONALD TRUMP IS SAYING
THIS IS A RAID BUT THAT'S A
GROSS EXAGGERATION.
>> WE HAVE TO BE CAREFUL NOT TO
ADOPT THE TERM RAID.
>> THIS WAS NOT A RAID, IT IS
NOT A RAID.
>> IT'S NOT A RAID.
>> TRUMP TALKS ABOUT A RAID ON
HIS HOME.
NO, MAN THERE WAS NO RAID ON
YOUR HOME.
>> LET'S BE POLITE AND CALL IT A
SEARCH AND NOT A RAID.
>> IT WASN'T A RAID ON HIS
HOUSE.
NO DOORS WERE KICKED DOWN.
>> AMAZING HOW THEY SOUND ALL
ALIKE.
SO IT'S NOT A RAID BECAUSE NO
DOORS WERE KICKED DOWN.
SEE, I DON'T THINK YOU NEED TO
KICK A DOOR DOWN WHEN YOU'RE
ARMED AND THE DOOR'S ALREADY
OPEN FOR YOU, YOU BUTT HEAD.
I'M SORRY.
IS HE BUTTHEAD OR BEAVIS?
I KEEP FORGETTING.
TOO MEAN.
AND, YEAH, IT WAS JUST A SEARCH,
NOT A RAID.
MORE LIKE AN EASTER EGG HUNT, A
BACHELORETTE SCAVENGER HUNT.
IT WAS EARLY TRICK OR TREATING
AND THEY WERE JUST DRESSED UP AS
COPS.
SO NOW THE MEDIA CARES ABOUT
WORDS AFTER COMPLETELY
MISTREATING THE ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LIKE THEY WERE KEVIN SPACEY AT
THE LITTLE LEAGUE WORLD SERIES.
WHAT ARE YOU MOANING ABOUT?
A WOMAN'S NO LONGER A WOMAN.
A RECESSION IS NO LONGER A
RECESSION.
NOW A RAID IS A SEARCH.
SO FUNNY WATCHING THE MEDIA
TRYING TO PLAY THIS OFF AS A
TRIFLE WHEN YOU KNOW IF IT
HAPPENED TO ONE OF THEIR OWN
THEY'D BLOW UP LIKE PAUL
PELOSI'S AIRBAG.
WONDER WHAT HE'S UP TO.
>> Greg: HE'LL BE OUT IN NO
TIME.
BUT MAYBE WE'LL SEE HOW THEY
REACT WHEN INEVITABLY IT HAPPENS
TO HUNTER AND JOE.
THEY ASSUME THEY'RE ABOVE THE
LAW MUCH LIKE MOST DEMOCRATS
WHEN DEMOCRATS ARE IN POWER.
BUT DO THEY EVER THINK AHEAD?
THEY WON'T ALWAYS BE IN POWER.
OF COURSE, THE WHITE HOUSE
CLAIMS JOE HAD NO IDEA OF THE
RAID ON A LIVING PRESIDENT.
HOW AMAZING IS THAT?
I MEAN, I GET HIDING THINGS FROM
JOE, LIKE HIS CAR KEYS, PONY
TAILS.
BUT THIS IS KIND OF A BIG DEAL.
I WONDER, YOU KNOW, WHAT'S GOING
ON IN MR. BIDEN'S NEIGHBORHOOD.
♪♪
>> HI, NEIGHBOR.
LOOK, LOOK, YOU MIGHT HAVE HEARD
ABOUT A RAID.
THERE WASN'T ANY RAID.
THERE WAS NO RAID.
IT WAS A, JUST A NEIGHBORLY
VISIT.
IT'S A NEIGHBOR POPPING IN ON A
NEIGHBOR UNEXPECTED.
IT'S FUN.
YOU GO THROUGH THE CLOSETS
AND -- YOU KNOW WHAT'S IN MY
CLOSET?
A SWEATER.
I LOVE SWEATERS, DON'T YOU?
I LOVE COMING HOME AT THE END OF
THE DAY, PUTTING ON A SWEATER.
HOLD ON A SECOND.
♪♪
>> Greg: HA HA HA HA.
MEANWHILE DURING ALL THIS
HILLARY IS IF YOU UNDERSTAND
RAISING OFF HER OWN CRIME.
SHE'S SELLING MERCH OFF THE BACK
OF THE MAR-A-LAGO RAID POSTING
AN IMAGE OF A NEW PIECE OF
CLOTHING ON HER TWITTER ACCOUNT
WHICH BORE THE SLOGAN BUT HER
E-MAILS.
A REFERENCE TO HER SCANDAL MUCH
HER PRIVATE E-MAIL SERVER WHICH
SHE'S MOCKING.
SHE PROMOTED IT MONDAY SAYING
EVERY HAT SOLD WOULD HELP DEFEND
DEMOCRACY AND ALSO HELP MALE
PATTERN BALDNESS OF ANY
FEMINIST.
BUT HER E-MAILS SO CUTE.
WHY STOP THERE I CAN SEE A FEW
MORE CLINTON RELATED SWAG ALONG
THE SAME LINES BUT HER E-MAILS.
HOW ABOUT BUT HER BLUE DRESS?
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: BUT HIS MISSING CIGAR.
BUT HER GETTING SHELLACKED IN
2016.
AND, FINALLY, I KNOW THIS ONE
WILL TAKE UP A LOT OF ROOM ON
THE HAT BUT GOT TO DO IT.
WHEN BILL GOES TO PEDOPHILE
ISLAND AND EPSTEIN GETS
MURDERED.
I'M KIDDING.
I KID YA OLD BAG.
THE FACT IS THERE'S DIFFERENT
RULES FROM THESE ELITES THAN
OTHERS.
TRUMP WAS THE OPPOSITE OF ELITE.
NEXT JAY-Z AND DR. DRE THE MOST
FREE WILLED MILLIONAIRE EVER.
LIKE KILMEADE'S TAPE WORM THEY
COULDN'T CONTROL HIM.
NOW THEY SAY AN FBI INFORMANT IN
HIS OWN HOUSE.
PRETTY GROSS RIGHT.
BUT WHAT DO YOU EXPECT FROM A
GOVERNMENT WHO HELPED ORGANIZE
THE KIDNAPPING OF MICHIGAN
GOVERNOR GRETCHEN WHITMER.
GAVIN NEWSOME WOULD HAVE BEEN SO
EASIER APPROACH HIM WITH A VAN
OF HAIR GEL.
IF YOU FIND A CRIME YOU CAN
CREATE IT.
THE ONLY PROBLEM IS IT'S GOING
TO COME BACK TO HAUNT YOU.
RIGHT?
IF THE REPUBLICANS TAKE BACK THE
HOUSE THEY SHOULD RAID BIDEN.
I CAN PICTURE IT FBI LEAVING
WITH 15 BOX OF OATMEAL DENTURE
CREAM AND NOTEBOOKS.
BUT AS BIDEN ONCE SAID AS HE
ENTERED THE BUNNY RANCH, GAME ON
BITCHES.
>> PERIOD.
>> Greg: LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUESTS.
HE'S COVERED MORE NEWS THAN A
CARROT WITH DIARRHEA, HOST OF
SPECIAL REPORT BRET BAIER!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: HE'S NUTIER THAN A
PORTA POTTY A. A PEANUT
FESTIVAL.
FOX BUSINESS MANAGER DAGEN
McDOWELL.
SHE'S LIKE THE MAG NAH CARD A,
DIFFICULT TO READ AND COVERED.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
AND ANACONDAS ARE HIS DENTAL
FLOSS.
MY SIDE KICK AND THE NWA WORLD
CHAMPION TYRUS!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE] I.
>> LET ME JUST SAY I THINK YOU
BROUGHT THE HEAT TONIGHT.
>> Greg: THANK YOU.
>> Bret: THIS WAS A TOP NOTCH
MONOLOGUE.
I LOVE THE SHOW BUT I'M ALWAYS
AMAZED THAT ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS COME ON MY SHOW AFTER
WATCHING THE MONOLOGUE.
>> Greg: YEAH, IT IS KIND OF
STRANGE THAT SOME OF THE THINGS
I'M DOING.
BUT I KNOW YOU'RE TRYING TO
BUTTER ME UP BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T
READ THE TOPICS.
>> Bret: I READ TWO IN BETWEEN
THE SHOW, I READ --
>> Greg: YOU DON'T HAVE TO READ,
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS SAY WHAT
YOU SAID ALREADY TODAY.
THAT'S WHAT EVERYBODY DOES.
>> Bret: OKAY.
>> Greg: SO WHERE DO YOU SEE
THIS GOING, RIGHT?
DO YOU THINK THERE'S ACTUALLY
GOING TO BE SOMETHING THERE?
BECAUSE IF THERE'S NOTHING THERE
THEN MERRICK GARLAND LOOKS
PRETTY BAD.
>> Bret: REALLY BAD.
IF IT DOES NOT DELIVER IT LOOKS
REALLY BAD.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL SAID THEY
FILED AN UNSEALED SEARCH WARRANT
THAT'S THE NEXT BATTLE AND WILL
COME TO A HEAD TOMORROW.
>> Greg: I COULDN'T UNDERSTAND
ANY OF THE LEGAL STUFF.
THE WARRANT ISN'T THE THING IT'S
THE AFFIDAVIT RIGHT?
WE WERE GOING AROUND AND AROUND
AND AROUND ON THE FIVE AND I WAS
LIKE GET ME THE HELL OUT OF
HERE.
>> Bret: THE JUDGE WAS AGAINST
HAROLD.
>> Greg: I WAS LIKE JUST GET A
ROOM.
>> Bret: IT'S GOING TO BE
FASCINATING TOMORROW BUT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS IF IT'S ABOUT
DOCUMENTS AND CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS AND WHETHER HE SHOULD
HAVE THEM OR NOT, I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
SAY, THERE'S GOT TO BE MORE
THERE.
>> Greg: YEAH.
YOU KNOW, DAGAN, YOU HAVE A
CHOICE.
YOU CAN TALK ABOUT THAT, YOU CAN
TALK ABOUT HILLARY TRYING TO
MAKE SOME DOUGH, YOU CAN TALK
ABOUT ANYTHING YOU WANT.
EXCEPT WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
GREEN ROOM THAT WAS NOT MY
FAULT.
>> Dagen: SINCE YOU OPENED
COMPARING ME TO A PORT A JOHN
FULL OF [BLEEP]
>> Greg: DID I?
>> Tyrus: YEAH.
>> Dagen: YOU DID.
>> Greg: AT A PEANUT FESTIVAL.
>> Dagen: AND SINCE YOU BOOKED
THE CHIEF POLITICAL CORESPONDENT
OR ANCHOR.
>> Bret: ANCHOR.
>> Dagen: YOU KNOW, LOOK AT THE
BIG BRAIN ON BRET.
I'M JUST GOING TO SIT OVER HERE
AND WORK UP SOME PICKUP TRUCK
JOKES AND JUST PICK MY TEETH AND
GLARE AT BRET AND MAKE HIM
UNCOMFORTABLE.
I CAN HIT -- THESE ARE
POLITICIANS ON THE LEFT THAT
DESERVE COME UPENS.
ONE, JUST STONE COLD STUPIDITY.
JOE BIDEN GO TO KIAWAH ISLAND IN
THE MIDDLE OF AUGUST?
NOBODY ON THE PLANET DOES THAT.
IT'S MUGGY, BUGGY.
YOU CAN'T PLAY GOLF BECAUSE THE
SWEAT RUNS FROM YOUR ARMPITS ALL
THE WAY DOWN THE CLUB.
AND THEN HILLARY, SHE'S THINKING
IN HER MIND SHE'S GOING TO GET
BACK IN THE GAME, AND SHE HASN'T
DUMPED THAT DROOLING WALL RUS OF
A HUSBAND YET?
>> Greg: THAT'S TRUE.
HE'S STILL THERE.
>> Dagen: NOW -- SHUT UP.
>> Greg: I APPLAUD
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: WHAT DO YOU THINK
TYRUS?
>> Tyrus: I THINK DAGAN'S GOING
TO KICK YOUR ASS AFTER THE SHOW.
>> Bret: I'M HOPING SHE DOESN'T
KICK MY ASS.
>> Tyrus: YOU'RE GOOD.
I GOT YOU.
>> Greg: YOU DEFEND HIM BUT NOT
ME.
>> Tyrus: YOU GOT IT COMING.
YOU SAID HER BURRS IS FULL OF
BATTERED CRAW FISH.
IN LOUISIANA THAT'S NOT A
COMPLIMENT.
YOU NEVER GET A, WHY, THANK YOU.
>> Dagen: YEAH, WOMEN SMELL LIKE
SEAFOOD, THAT'S A REAL FUN JOKE.
>> Tyrus: YEAH.
>> Greg: THAT'S NOT WHAT I
MEANT.
>> Tyrus: BRA, I WOULD BE ON AN
OCEAN FOR FIVE WEEKS WITH NO
ROOF AND SITTING NEXT TO A WOMAN
AND I STILL WOULDN'T SAY YOU
SMELL LIKE FISH, WHILE SHE'S
EATING A RAW SHARK IN HER TEETH,
I STILL WOULD SAY, WOW, IS THIS
LEMON.
>> Greg: I'M A PATRIOT YOU CAN'T
INSULT ME, ACCORDING TO MERRICK
GARLAND.
>> Tyrus: I JUST THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE REMEMBER,
WE'VE GOT TO LET THIS GO.
I JUST -- WHEN NOVEMBER COMES,
WE'VE GOT TO GET TO WORK.
WE CAN'T WASTE TIME CHASING.
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO FIND IN
BIDEN'S HOUSE, OPEN CANS OF
TAPIOCA EVERYWHERE?
NOTES, DEPENDS.
ANGRY POST ITS FROM HIS WIFE,
YOU KNOW, MAPS TO THE BATHROOM.
LIKE WE'RE NOT GOING TO FIND
ANYTHING WE WANT TO FIND.
THE SMART THING TO DO WAS TO
USHER HIM AWAY BECAUSE, COULD
YOU IMAGINE HIM ANSWERING THE
QUESTIONS RIGHT NOW?
RAID?
YOU KNOW, OR SEARCH?
HE WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO ANSWER
ANY OF THOSE QUESTIONS, BECAUSE
THEY WOULD BE RAIDING THE WHITE
HOUSE SEARCHING FOR HIM TO BRING
HIM TO THE FRONT.
SO THEY CONSIDER RID HIM AWAY
AND LET HIM STAY THERE AS THIS
BLOWS UP HIS FACE.
WHERE'S THE VP IN ALL THIS?
>> Greg: THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
WHERE IS SHE?
>> Tyrus: KAT
>> Kat: I DON'T KNOW.
>> Greg: DO YOU HAVE A REPORT ON
HER WHEREABOUTS TO READ TO US
RIGHT NOW
>> Kat: NO, I DON'T, I DON'T
THINK ANYBODY DOES.
WE KNOW SO LITTLE.
AND MERRICK GARLAND HEARING FROM
HIM TODAY, WHAT WAS THAT?
HE GOT UP THERE AND HE'S LIKE,
YEAH, I DID IT.
IT IS A BIG DEAL.
I AM GOING TO UNSEAL THE
WARRANT.
IN THE MEANTIME PLEASE REMEMBER
THAT THE FBI RULES.
LIKE, AND WE NEED MORE
INFORMATION BECAUSE NOW PEOPLE
SAYING THE SAME ONE OR TWO
THINGS BACK AND FORTH.
IT'S LIKE IF THIS WASN'T A BIG
DEAL THEN THEY REALLY OVERDID IT
AND THAT'S GOING TO MAKE TRUMP
WIN.
OR BECAUSE THEY DID ALL THIS
THIS MUST BE A BIG DEAL AND
TRUMP'S GOING TO JAIL.
AND THAT'S MY IMPRESSION OF
SPECIAL REPORT.
>> Greg:.
>> Greg: WHOA
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Bret: I WAS JUST GOING TO SAY
THIS WAS REALLY INSIGHTFUL AND
YOU COULD DEFINITELY BE ON THE
PANEL.
>> Greg: SHE HOLDS AND GRUDGE,
JUST EXPLODED.
>> Tyrus: I'VE BEEN ON THE
PANEL.
IT IS WONDERFUL.
MR. BAIER DOES A WONDERFUL JOB.
>> Greg: I DID NOT SEE THAT
COMING
>> Kat: I DON'T BELIEVE THAT,
THAT'S ALL THE GUYS AFTER I GOT
MARRIED SAYING I SHOULD HAVE
TAKEN YOU MORE SERIOUSLY.
LIKE NO.
[LAUGHTER].
>> Tyrus: WHEN I WAS ON HE EVEN
TOOK THE GLASSES OFF, YEAH, YOU
KNOW YOU ARER WHEN BRET BAIER
TAKES THE GLASSES OFF.
>> Bret: THEY'RE RIGHT OVER
HERE.
>> Greg: I DIDN'T EVEN PREDICT
THIS WOULD GO IN SUCH